there is something about comics that
stay in new york for a long time though
like david towel oh you know about dave
yeah yeah he wants to do this podcast he
does yeah i'm a huge fan of david oh
yeah but it's like it almost like he
doesn't
want to make it
i don't know i mean you probably know
him but like
it feels like you just
maybe it's romanticizing it but you're
like
you almost just love the art of comedy
like becoming funnier crafting the jokes
becoming funnier than the other comics
like competing with each other kind of
thing not over like money or fame or any
of that just just purely the comedy of
it totally that's dave that's him in a
nut he's like that guy in the movies in
the 80s action movies where they're like
they go up to a a creek in montana and
some guy's living in a cabin and he's
sharpening a stick and they go
the russians are coming they're invading
we need you you're the best commando and
he's like i gave that up man i'm done
with that lifestyle you're the best we
need you and he has to suit up
eventually you know he looks at a
picture of his dead wife and he goes
it i'm going and then they you know
fight the rooskies but uh he's that guy
he just is gifted he's like got a gift
from a la and he's the best
yeah a lot of comics give him props
that's always surprising to me i didn't
because because surprising to me because
he hasn't really made it like big he did
in the 90s he was huge he had his own tv
show he was
yeah that show that show was awesome but
i mean like as big as i think he
deserves to be so i well that's art the
mainstream is always the worst
it's like mcdonald's versus some hole in
the wall i know i'm on
mcdonald's again but
it's good and you know certain comics we
could name are good but
the the delicacy is gonna be less
talked about and less uh household namey
than
than the mainstream
hacky yeah it's funny because he
hasn't uh i think he was on
uh joe rogan's show once maybe yeah once
again and and he was with somebody else
um jeff wrong yeah he met him with jeff
ross oh yeah because they did that like
two mikes thing with mike's yeah yeah
um but he's the quickest guy there's no
one funnier
you